in this python algorithms course you
will learn to work with recursion data
structures greedy algorithms dynamic
programming and more
you don't need any previous experience
and algorithms to follow along
algorithms help us solve problems
efficiently and employers pay good money
for good problem solvers
your instructor for this course is joy
brock
she has an amazing talent for breaking
down complex topics using humor and
visualizations
[Music]
hi
can i ask you a question raise your hand
if you love being bossed around
i'm not seeing any hands
i know that i don't like to be bossed
around
now you might be wondering why i would
ask a question like that and what does
that have to do with computer algorithms
but that's just it
computers love to be lost around in fact
a computer can't do anything on its own
without being told what to do and that
my friends is what an algorithm is
an algorithm is a specific set of
instructions that we write to the
computer to tell it what to do after all
that's why you're here right to learn
how to tell that old ball and chain
who's boss you know the one that keeps
us perpetually locked in a prison of
screen time so without further ado
welcome to the introduction to
algorithms course i am so glad you're
here we are going to have an insane
amount of fun so grab your beverage of
choice grab a notepad for notes and be
prepared to learn the five basic
algorithms that every programmer should
know
by official definition an algorithm can
be defined as being the current term of
choice for a problem solving procedure
it is commonly used nowadays for the set
of rules a machine especially a computer
follows to achieve a particular goal it
does not always apply to computer
mediated activity however the term may
is accurately be used for the steps
followed in making a pizza or solving a
rubik's cube as for computer powered
data analysis
algorithms are often paired with words
specifying the activity for which a set
of rules have been designed
a search algorithm for example is a
procedure that determines what kind of
information is retrieved from a large
mass of data an encryption algorithm is
a set of rules by which information or
messages are encoded so that
unauthorized persons cannot read them
this comes from the merriam-webster
dictionary what does algorithm mean
mathematically speaking algorithms have
been around for nearly 900 years pretty
amazing isn't it in fact algorithms are
all around us every day and have been
our whole lives in this course we're
going to dive into algorithms that are
finite or determine sequences of
explicit instructions that are used to
solve problems and or perform
computations these computations are
generally to perform calculations or to
manipulate data using natural language
processing natural language processing
or nlp for short is what tells the
computer how to comprehend and interpret
written text
it's important to distinguish the
difference between using well-defined
formal languages to calculate functions
versus algorithms used in artificial
intelligence or machine learning
those algorithms are where automated
deductions are made using mathematical
and logical tests
or where predictions are made based on
patterns learned from experience for
example the other day when i was looking
at the front page of google on their
news i thought you know this algorithm
better be so good that i can read about
the news before it even happens
those types of algorithms are for
another video on another day
the objective here in this course is to
give you the tools you'll need to
undertake the journey of using a
well-defined formal language in this
case python to calculate functions
within a defined amount of space and
time that may be asked of you for
interviews or tests
in other words the goal is for you to be
able to
find differences in algorithmic
approaches based on computational
efficiency
this means that how we write our program
is very important in regards to how much
space it can use up on our computer or
how quickly it can run
and it all begins with the foundational
principles that every algorithm has
in input
well-defined instructions
execution of those instructions step by
step leading to an output that ends in
termination of the program
now there are many different algorithms
that accomplish
these basics when it comes to
programming and as much as i love
spending time with you all
it would be so difficult to cover every
single one so for the sake of brevity
we'll be covering the following
simple recursive algorithms
algorithms within data structures
divide and conquer
greedy algorithms
and last but certainly not least dynamic
programming
for this course you'll need some
understanding of the python language
like writing functions variables
conditionals for loops and basic syntax
an ide or integrated development
environment an ide is the virtual place
to write our programs
now if you don't have a downloaded
platform like pycharm jupiter notebook
or visual studio code you can just use
any online python ide through a google
search
if you would like to download your own
personal ide such as pycharm vsc or
jupiter you can definitely do that as
each one of those platforms are free to
install
go ahead and pause the video now if you
need to get situated otherwise let's get
this party started enroll into our very
first lesson on simple recursive
algorithms
in our first lesson we're going to learn
what is recursion and we're going to
examine three different problems ranging
from easy to mind-breaking
we're going to look at the differences
in computational efficiency and see
which approach is best
is implementing recursion the best way
let's find out
[Music]
if the easiest way to define recursion
is to say it's where a function calls
itself then what's the hard way to
define it in all truth it's easy to
throw a statement out hand on hip that
goes oh it's a function that calls
itself
sure okay good for you but what does
that really mean i think oftentimes when
it comes to programming it's easy to
take for granted this idea that we
should automatically know what it all
means
i don't know about you but i wasn't born
with the ability to comprehend various
methods to solve problems let alone be
able to decipher which which method is
better in the first place you know
we all need to learn these concepts
layer upon layer step by step so let's
start at the very first layer and build
up from there now when we write our
program recursively it's important to
understand that this is in contrast to
writing it iteratively or through
iteration when we do that we're
generally using for loops to iterate
over an object instead of making a
function call back within the program
you'll see what i mean when we get into
our ides and and start to write the code
recursion
is it originates from a latin verb that
means to run back and this is what the
program we're going to write together is
going to do it will run back to itself
over and over as many times as it needs
until the program terminates so does
this mean that we can't use for loops
with recursion no of course you can use
them in fact they will be needed and
you'll see how that all works in just a
moment in order to get started with our
very first lesson involving factorials
and the algorithmic method that we are
going to use for better efficiency we
will calculate the factorial of a number
using the leaf method or last in first
out and it all begins with a mental
picture of a bookshelf that doesn't have
any books on it yet to perform a lethal
operation on your hypothetical bookshelf
you will grab some books and begin
placing them on the shelf let's say you
ordered some britannica encyclopedias
wait why would you do that
why did any of us do that oh right it
was our grandparents that saw to it to
make sure that we had our own modern day
google machine thanks grandma your
legacy lives on at the donation center
okay that was a wonderful trip down
memory lane wasn't it okay so back to
lefo or lifo if that's what you call it
so you put your encyclopedias on the
shelf a to z in a last in first out
scenario what was the last book you you
sat on the shelf z what's the first book
that's going to come off z
so last in first out and this would be
important to remember in our number
oriented recursive function coming up
that the last number that goes in will
be the first number that gets called out
or computed
now if you're a little bit confused it's
okay you won't be for long we're going
to see this in action right now and talk
about the computationally efficient way
to solve as we write our first recursive
program to calculate the factorial of a
number
for a quick recap on factorials say you
take the number 5 and multiply it by
itself minus 1 all the way down until
you hit one
your answer will equal 120. remember
factorials only involve positive
integers so once you hit one the program
terminates
now let's get to work
we're going to look at two ways that we
can write a program that will calculate
the factorial of a number this is going
to be a wonderful foray into differences
regarding complexity and program
efficiency in our first method we're
going to tackle this iteratively or like
i mentioned before through iteration
this means that our program will cycle
through or iterate each and every step
we tell it to
first we define our function with one
parameter the number we want to
calculate in this case we'll just call
it n
then we're going to create a variable
and start it at one positive numbers
remember no zeros here next we construct
a for loop to iterate over that variable
or object if you like
and do something to it in this case
we're going to multiply it by every
number in a range starting at 2 and
adding in our ending at our number plus
one this gives us a range of four
numbers two three four five now why not
six since n or five plus one equals six
remember we're using python so if we
loop to a range of two
comma 6 in parenthesis our indices will
always be minus 1 because python starts
at 0. so an index position of 6 will
give us our last number for our
calculation 5. then we take our object
called fact and multiply it by every
number in our range because we can use
the asterisk and equal sign to condense
our code a little fact equals fact time
asterisk i that assignment operator is
reassigning our variable each time it
cycles through our loop
when the cycling or iteration is
finished we simply return our finished
fact variable if you want to see the
results of each
iteration you can just place a print
statement within the for loop and run
the program
for a recursive method it's going to be
already typed out while i talk
this is where our last in first out
comes into play remember when we talked
about that this is in contrast to our
iterative method that starts at the top
are fact variables starting at 1 and
then iterates through our range going up
until our number is reached in the
algorithmic method of recursion
when we go to call the function if our
number isn't 1 it moves to our else
statement where in our else statement we
have a temp variable that runs back to
our function call and creates a pocket
of space if you will for each number
minus one
it will run back all the way down until
it hits one our last n if you will once
that happens the return statement and
our else statement starts working its
magic and then we start heading back up
our last in which was one becomes our
first out
our first number to get computed
ta-da
[Applause]
now you might be tempted to think that
the recursive method is top dog here but
alas you'd be wrong our iterative method
is twice as fast
for what we're trying to accomplish
which is
just a basic calculation of a factorial
what's important what's important to be
able to understand is a how recursion
works by using a simple program such as
momentous did and b how how and why one
approach can be better than another
in this case recursion is taking up more
space and time by running back to the
function call to create those pockets
for our numbers
versus iteration where it's simply
multiplying each number in place and not
creating anything new
it's simply iterating over each number
reassigning our variable each time and
producing a final output
the objective for our basic exercise is
to just understand and see recursive
algorithms in action so that as you gain
experience you'll be able to exercise
different modes of expression or
expressivity in your writing
and in some cases use your readability
check out this example
on the upside being able to write
code in three lines instead of seven or
eight can be a huge deal depending on
the circumstance however on the flip
side may decrease the performance of the
code let's like this example that we
just coded together
it's just not as efficient as iteration
in this case so if you're ready let's
move up to a more advanced recursive
algorithm involving permutations
a permutation is when you take a set of
elements and find all the different
variations that can be made with it for
instance if we take a b and c we can get
six variations out of these three
letters mathematically speaking we can
find the number of variations by
calculating the factorial of the
elements just like we did a few minutes
ago
for a hands-on approach to understanding
a level up on recursion let's take a
peek under the hood and see how this
will work in a program shelby
[Music]
the underlying basis of how most
functions for permutations work is to
take off the first element and then
create two subsets of numbers that get
swapped like this
then the original first element gets put
back onto the front of each subset then
we do this all over again this time
instead of popping out the first element
we pop out the second one and create two
new subsets and so on and so forth
the algorithm behind permutations can
really make your head spin so take a
deep breath
find your center and jump in
to
a puddle
let's not jump into the ocean just yet
it's good to start small and by small
let's recursively swap just two letters
of a string this is a little bit harder
to do than a list because strings are
immutable but
this is a good launch point for us to
build up from here also we'll start with
recursion this time and then afterwards
we'll look at a different method for
comparison
to write a recursive function that will
swap just two letters we will need to
create a pocket for where our strings
need to go remember again strings are
immutable and if this were a list we
could simply slice it and create a
variable swap but that's a no go for
strings we're moving into a little bit
steeper territory here but stay with me
okay you can do this
let's create our function and call it
permute with two parameters one called
string and for the string of two letters
that we want to swap and an empty pocket
to put our new string in this is our
parameter default defaulted to an empty
string then we create an if statement
for an edge case in the event that the
string is empty and if it's empty we
just return our empty pocket now we'll
start with looping through the range of
the length of our string and within our
loop we'll start with creating three
variables that will contain one each
letter on our string two we'll need to
take off the front of the string that
we're going to call front and then three
a variable called back that will slice
off the back of our string if you study
this algorithm you'll see some
programmers call it head and tail
current and the rust first next or front
and back i like the terms front and back
as it gives me a better mental picture
but you can use whatever terms you're
more comfortable with
now those first three variables are
fairly obvious but this is where it
might get a little hazy we need to
create a fourth variable that will put
our front and back together and we'll
need this variable of combined elements
to plug into our function call
this is what creates spaces to in our
pocket to be able to move our letters
around i know this may sound a little
complicated at the moment but you'll see
shortly that we're going to need each
and every letter of our string even
however many that will eventually come
to be to have the space it needs to go
into the right place in our pocket now
whether that's going to lead up to
eventually being three letters or four
keep in mind our strengths can't be too
long because of two things the rate of
exponential growth and the fact that
recursion can get exhaustive very fast
the more letters you have recursively
that's a lot of running back okay we
have all the variables we need right now
our letter a front which is just an
empty string right now our back which is
the last set of our string b
and are together that combines our front
and back now for our algorithm this is
where the magic happens this is the true
ham in our sandwich we call our function
premium and then incorporate two
parameters are together
and our letter added to our pocket hence
the addition operator
this is the heartbeat of our algorithm
it needs to run back and put our letters
into our pocket once in reverse and then
the second time in a copy of its
original form because it's still
considered a permutation watch how this
works in the visualizer
i think that if you get really get a
really good handle on this concept and
you have a solid foundation
it becomes so much easier to see how
this works with additional letters if
you can see it mentally this makes all
the difference in the world
it's a neat little program that only has
11 lines of code which is really nice
however this program isn't as efficient
as a program that uses iteration and
swapping again
that program has nearly double the lines
of code i'll spare you the direction of
watching me type it all out and just
show you here
this would be the code that executes
just like the beginning
[Music]
that you saw on the earlier slides where
it pops off the first letter and then
swaps the it pops out the first letter
swaps the last two and then
pops the first letter back on then it
rotates to the second letter
swaps those two
and then puts it back on
check the output here and you'll see
what i mean now if you needed to know
all the permutations of a string and
don't really have time to write the code
or the patience you could use the inner
tools permutations module it's really
easy
but
that would be primarily for you
just to know for yourself or for a quick
look up when it comes to interviews or
testing companies would generally prefer
that you know the mechanics behind the
method for solving whether that's using
recursion or swapping
as with any program the caveat must
always be made can this program be
written differently
as always yes however you will see very
little difference when it comes to
recursion of most programs like this
very generally speaking they will call
the function in a very similar way as it
is written here by taking the front and
back together and incorporating it in
some way
within the function call
along with the letter
hopefully you were able to distinctly
see how recursion works in this program
even just for two letters
it can work great on small strings but
it will get computationally expensive
the longer the string now if you're not
too overwhelmed hopefully not we've only
done two
we're going to move into the mind
breaker section like it should be the
mind blowing section
the end cleans
problem
this computational problem is about
placing eight chess queens on an eight
by eight board so that no two queens are
able to attack each other according to
wikipedia the problem finding all
solutions to the eight queens problem
can be quite computationally expensive
there are 4 billion possible
arrangements of the 8 queens on an 8x8
board but only 92 solutions wikipedia
also goes on to say that the use of
shortcuts and various rules of thumb
that avoid brute force techniques can
greatly reduce the number of possible
combinations which i'm sure is always a
good thing but what is brute force
though
well that's would be brute force would
be looking at every single possible
arrangement 4 billion of them to find
the 92 solutions how long do you think
that would take
probably take decades for our computers
to run a program like that but guess
what the use of permutations can reduce
the possibilities from 4 billion down to
just 40 000. that's a big reduction
now we're not are we going to use
permutations on the end queen's problem
today no way jose
but it's good to know that this problem
is often used in examples for various
programming techniques such as solving
it by using recursive algorithms it's
also used
as an example in constraint programming
which is a paradigm for solving
combinatorial problems that draws on a
wide range of techniques from artificial
intelligence computer science and
operations research
to get a better idea of what that would
be we can use a real world example like
employee scheduling say for instance a
company operates continuously like a
factory they need to create weekly
schedules for their employees and if
that company runs three eight hour
shifts per day in a science three of its
four employees different shifts each day
while giving a fourth one's a day off
even in such a small case like that the
number of possible schedules is huge
each day there are factorially 24
possible employee assignments for four
people
so the number of possible weekly
schedules is 247 which calculates over
4.5 billion
constraint programming methods keep
track of which solutions remain feasible
and makes it a powerful tool for solving
real world
scheduling problems who knew queens on a
chessboard combined with computer
programming could help solve real world
problems like that
so what did we learn in our very first
lesson in our algorithms course
we learned simple recursion and saw it
in action that when a function calls
itself it creates new spaces to store
information and sometimes this may not
be an efficient solution to a problem
it's definitely more elegant with fewer
lines of code
that can come in handy depending on the
problem but it's not always cost
effective
but it is important to see and
understand the difference
factorials and permutations are used in
a lot of computational mathematical and
real world applications
learning how to write programs rather
recursively or iteratively to find the
best method
in this area can go a long way and may
lead to unknown opportunities for you
down the road as a programmer
we learned about constraint programming
where recursion plays a role for solving
mind-bending problems
not only within board games such as
chess but real life issues that
companies can face
as a programmer that works to gain the
tools needed to understand these types
of methods to solve problems can make
them a valuable asset to any company
[Music]
welcome to level two
working with data
that is structured i like to think of
data structures like something that
holds money say for instance you have on
your person a big wad of cash consisting
of a lot of different bills what could
you do with it well you could store it
sort it search it add it spend it
delete it
count it so with data structures they're
simply containers or collections of data
they provide a means of managing small
or large amounts of values for uses and
such things like
databases web traffic monitoring user
registrations and or indexing within a
contiguous memory location like an array
they can range from as simple as lists
to linked lists stacks cues hash tables
trees and heaps
these are all examples of data
structures and since algorithms are
steps to solving problems what kind of
problem-solving techniques are common
with data structures well just like
watts of cache data often needs storage
sorting counting retrieving searching
spending all those fun things now arrays
can be a really basic container for
information but don't let that fool you
many different algorithms can be used on
one-dimensional arrays but what about
two-dimensional arrays what about 32
dimensions since that's the maximum
amount can you imagine
arrays are among the oldest and most
important data structures and are used
for almost every program for a basic
level of algorithms with data structures
we'll go easy and stick to a linear or
one-dimensional array
a one-dimensional array is just an array
stored in an unbroken block of memory to
access the next value in an array we
just move sequentially to the next
memory address it's best to see this
visually so check these slides out for a
better idea
in our basic section we're going to
cover
linear search binary search
bubble sort
and insertion sort
we'll be covering a little bit more for
the basic level on data structures
because it's a really big topic actually
entire books are written about them let
alone design techniques and algorithms
i'll do my best not to put you to sleep
hopefully it'll be enough to watch your
appetite where array is our concern as
this is a huge topic as well and as much
as python is a wonderful program with
tons of features like built-ins and
libraries and modules that can help
programmers code faster it's still
really important to understand how these
features work algorithmically and the
concepts underneath it all
let's get started
a linear search could be equated to
pulling that a lot of cash out of your
wallet
wait does anyone carry cash anymore no
okay well let's pretend that you have a
wallet full of really big bills i mean
go big or go home right and you need a
500 bill from your stack
why well you're at the mall of course
and you want to buy that really cool
pair of socks that you saw in the window
and you might be thinking 500 for a pair
of socks and i would say yup that's
inflation for you but this is a fantasy
remember besides inflation slomation you
got a wallet full of big bills and in
this fantasy let's go for a big ticket
item
well maybe not sucks but maybe a t-shirt
in a linear or sequential search we
could technically transpose transposo
those terms you would have to go through
each bill to find that 500 same with an
array of say six random integers
if we were wanting to find the eight we
we would have to manually check each
element in order to return the position
of the eight
algorithmically it would look like this
and can you imagine if we had an array
containing a large amount of numbers it
would be very very time consuming and
inefficient to use a linear search
because it would be comparing each
integer one by one
now can it be used for searching sure
but it's only when the numbers are
relatively few and relatively sorted but
hey let's code this out anyway we'll
define our function with two parameters
our array and the element that we're
searching for then we'll write a for
loop to iterate over the length of our
array and if there is an element there
that's the same as our element then just
return where it is in the array when we
print it out we get index position 4 as
that is where our 10 is
a more efficient way to search is to
move up to a binary search and the clue
is in the name binary as in by meaning
something that has two parts
in this search algorithm we would create
two pointers and repeatedly divide the
search interval by half naturally this
would reduce our search space so that
we're not searching the whole array but
only the divided parts
the catches at the binary search
is that it is usually mostly
generally
done on sorted arrays that looks like
this
and this way the algorithm checks
whether the middle element is equal to
the target that we're searching for in
every iteration if the target value
matches the element then its position in
the array is returned if the if the
target value is less than the element
the search continues in the lower half
of the array the target value is greater
than it searches in the upper half of
the array ultimately the algorithm
doesn't need to search the half our
target isn't in with each iteration
now let's look at some code
because our program is only searching
half the array it makes it a much better
search
let's look at the iterative method first
in our function we can create four
parameters our array a start point an
endpoint
and the target that we're searching for
we'll create a while loop to iterate
over our array from start to end and
then create our midpoint our variable
called mid is the magic in the sauce we
only want to traverse the half that
contains our element feel free to print
out the mid when you run the whole
program for yourself to get a good idea
of this
next we can implement our if statements
we'll only need three
check if our target is in the upper half
then reassign our start to begin moving
to the right of the array
if our target is lower than our mid we
reassign our end to begin moving to the
left of the array if our target matches
our mid then just return it easy peasy
then we just return our start or we can
return something like negative one to
print out some strings to make it a
little fancy
but either way you prefer to have your
results printed we have to be sure to
declare our start and end in the
function call our start is zero from the
beginning of the array and our end is
the last element
our length of array minus one
for our recursive function i won't spend
a lot of time here because the
difference between our iterative program
and the recursive program is very
minimal runtime and memory space is very
very close meaning they're both really
efficient
either way it's good to see both
programs
basically all we're doing is just
calling back to the original function
within our else statements
feel free to pause the video for a
moment and take a closer look
okay now that we have some super basic
searches under our belt let's move into
a deeper section of sorting because well
sorting is fun
who doesn't like to sort money piles of
50s here piles of honey is there
holy crap i sound like mr krabs
all right all right let's mix the money
references let's get to sorting our
boring old elements
as for sorting there are a vast array of
techniques
that are available and here's a little
quick list
actually
it's not that quick as there are many to
choose from
bubble sort is the simplest sorting
algorithm that works by repeatedly
swapping the adjacent elements if they
are in the wrong order for instance the
largest integer bubbles up to the top or
iterates its way to the end of the array
through a comparison of each element
although this isn't a very efficient
algorithm perhaps the worst it's still
an important concept to understand the
only real perk the bubble sort has
compared to other algorithms is its
built-in ability to detect whether or
not an array is sorted in the first
place in a best case scenario the list
is already sorted or nearly sorted and
this is in contrast to other algorithms
even those with better than average
performance whose entire sorting process
caused more causes more inversions
reversals reversals or swaps to happen
an optimized algorithm for the bubble
sort is to find the nth largest element
and put it at the end of the array there
is an unoptimized version that you can
check out for comparison purposes if you
want to look that up on your own you're
more than welcome to do that but the
optimized version is done so that the
inner loop can avoid having to look all
the way at the end when it's running the
last iteration it's just saving time and
energy by not having to do that although
bubble sort is one of the simplest
sorting algorithms to understand and
implement its performance means that
it's that its efficiency decreases
dramatically on arrays of larger amounts
of elements and it's even been argued
that it shouldn't even be taught anymore
as it's outdated and is even hazardous
to some cpus
yikes i bet you didn't realize that
you'd be entering dangerous territory
here i mean who knew conan could be
fraught with such tenuous escapades such
as this
how sexy
let's code it
our function will take just one
parameter our array
and then i implemented an iteration
count just for informational purposes
next we create a for loop to iterate
over our indices in the array going to
the right combined with a nested loop
inside that iterates over our indices
going left
or reverse that we're going to call j
i strongly encourage you to write this
program for yourself and within our
nested loop print out j just to see it
in action
we have our iteration counter when this
prints you'll see why i added this now
we just tell it to swap elements if they
are lower than the one to the left in
our if statement if our element to the
left is greater then swap it
then we just return our newly sorted
array so let's print this so you can see
our iteration count
with 36 iterations that's pretty
efficient
check this out now i know i said that it
wasn't going to look at the unoptimized
but guys check this out double the
iterations for two functions and it's
double the code
i liked our first program
simple shorter faster
unstable
oh
that was dangerous i kind of like it but
hey if dangerous not your thing you
thrive in a more stable and secure
environment that's fine too we can
totally move on to the insertion sort
algorithm insertion sort is another
simple sorting algorithm that builds the
final array one item at a time
it's still inefficient on large lists
like the bubble sore but it can have
some advantages such as simple
implementation meaning a reduced amount
of code and performs well in small data
sets and relatively sorted arrays and it
doesn't require much space meaning that
it can be done in place therefore not
using much computer memory in order to
perform well the concept of the
insertion sort is to split the array
into two sections in order to compare
its elements we can consider one side
sorted and the other side unsorted our
algorithm takes one element at a time
from the unsorted side and compares it
to our elements on the sorted side
if our element is larger or smaller it
places it where it needs to be on our
sorted side each generation takes an
element from the unsorted side and
places it into our sorted side all the
way till there are no more elements to
compare to
and in the end we are left with a sorted
array
for our program our parameter in our
function call will be our array starting
with a for loop that will iterate
starting at our second element we don't
need to start at our first integer
because that's our sorted side
we leave that alone for now we create
two variables our key which is our
current element and a pointer to the
left of our key
we'll implement a while loop to iterate
as long as our index is greater or equal
to zero and our index is greater than
our key
we then program it to reassign the
larger one to the right position and
then move down and put our small element
to the left
we do this all in place without creating
extra space
it's fairly simple and straight to the
point
working with arrays can last for days
you like that no but seriously what
we've touched on is only the tip of the
iceberg as a personal challenge to
yourself try searching and sorting a
two-dimensional array are you up to the
challenge
for our advanced level algorithm section
we're going to dive into linked lists a
linked list is a linear data structure
in which the elements are are not stored
at contiguous memory locations
remember this picture
also remember that arrays are stored at
contiguous memory locations
a wikipedia definition states a linked
list is a linear collection of data
elements whose order is not given by
their physical placement in memory
instead each element points to the next
it's a data structure consisting of a
collection of nodes which together
represent a sequence in its most basic
form each node contains data and a
reference in other words a link to the
next node in the sequence
this structure allows for efficient
insertion or removal of elements from
any position in the sequence during
iteration
more complex variants and additional
links allowing more efficient insertion
or removal of nodes at arbitrary
positions a drawback of linked lists is
that access time is linear and difficult
to pipeline
some say that linked lists are among the
simplest and most common data structures
are they though
as an example
think of a photo storage website if you
click on the website landing page this
would be considered your header
then
when you click on the first image this
would become a node
the arrow next to it that you can click
to see the next picture would be your
pointer
now if you get to the third or fourth
picture and want to go back to the first
picture
and look at that again
those back arrows would mean that you're
on a doubly linked list
a doubly linked list means that you can
traverse the list forward and backward
however for this lesson we're only going
to cover a list that we can go forward
on the singly linked list
now the upside of a linked list over a
conventional array is that the list
elements can be easily inserted or
removed without re allocation or
reorganization of the entire structure
because the data items do not need to be
stored contiguously
linked lists allow insertion and removal
of nodes at any point in the list and
they keep up with a constant number of
operations by storing the link previous
to any link being added or removed
during a list traversal so let's talk
about our four basic algorithms or
common problem solving operations for
singly linked lists
every programmer needs to be able to do
the following traverse a linked list or
be able to travel along the nodes and
pointers
search a list for the header a node or
tail a tail is the last and final node
insert a new header note or tail
and to delete a note or tail a link to
list generally always needs a header
let's create a simple linked list
representing a small family member group
we want to be able to do all the
operations mentioned above this will
require a little bit of object oriented
programming so hopefully you are
somewhat familiar with that but if not
that's okay we'll stay simple and make
it easy peasy
we need our pretty standard class node
and class linked list to start our nodes
will be our family members and our
linked list will represent our whole
family this can be considered a little
backwards but i like to instantiate our
objects first so it's easier to see what
we're dealing with being able to
visualize what we're doing is an
important skill in programming and
design because it helps us think about
the big picture throughout the solution
let's picture our knowns as a family of
mom dad and two kids we'll create our
family head as bob his wife amy our
header will point to amy as the next
node and then our two little nodes max
and jenny they all need to point to each
other as they will be linked together in
our list so we will make sure our
pointers are created which is
object.next
everything looks good and we have all
our members individually as nodes but to
really see our algorithm in action we
need to link all our members together in
our linked list where we can operate on
that list and design them to be really
complex or really simple
linked list problems are often used as
interview and exam questions so knowing
how to create linked lists how to
traverse them how to add and take away
elements is very important once you get
really familiar with those concepts you
can move into learn learning how to
traverse how to reverse a list swap
elements maybe even go on to doubly
linked lists or circular
it's a really big topic to explore and
fun too and if you're not having fun
why are why are you here like why
so back to our family
let's get them created and then set it
up to where we can traverse this family
list
once we have established our class we
just need to implement our functions
that tell our linked list class what to
do
this is where we implement all the
things we need done with our nodes and
the first thing we're going to do is
make our nodes by creating the data and
a pointer
let's create our objects
then create pointers that go to each
family member
now that we have our nodes we can now
link them in a list by creating our
linked list class this is where we
create a function to traverse our nodes
in a list and be able to print them all
out
we only need one argument self because
it doesn't need any other value or input
to be to be able to do what we need
which is starting at our header and
printing them all out next by next by
nuts
then we just call family.traversal
and out pops our family members now if
you want to shoot these out in a
particular way such as in a list or
fancy strings that would have to be done
within another function in the linked
list class which unfortunately is not
within the scope of this course that's
more in tune with object oriented
programming a whole other separate topic
the goal here is to focus on being able
to operate or solve problems to creating
simple function calls on linked lists
now our family member list is looking
pretty good but word on the street is
that bob isn't treating amy too well and
he's been running around on her
from the looks of it bob might be
packing his bags and leaving the family
but it's not all bad because dave has
been hanging around a bit and although
he's bob's brother he's a really good
guy
i know i know it sounds really back once
but seriously dave is going to step up
to the plate and he's looking forward to
being a dunkle to the kids
you know you know a dunkle like when
your uncle becomes your dad and it's not
weird at all
so for our list we need to put dave as
the new header position and because this
is a computer and it can't do anything
that we don't tell it to do we need to
implement some functions
let's call it insert new header
and this is going to fall under our
insertion algorithm
we need to know how to insert elements
into the list and not only that we have
to tell it where to insert for davis the
new head we are going to put him at the
front of the list
so for our function apart from self we
need new data or information to be added
to the parameter since we are adding a
new name
our new name is our new node so we will
need our node class
remember the nodes are our family
members then all we need to do is assign
him as the next new node to the
self.head and then assign yourself.head
to the new node let's traverse the list
now
oh boy bob is still in the picture and
you know what amy can't have her new
hubby under the same roof as her ex that
is just not gonna work this is a little
two backwoods so bob needs to
go go
creating our new header simply pushed
all our nodes down so we need to get bob
out of there let's create a function
that deletes a node however we can't
just delete some rando node we have to
tell our computer where bob the node is
in the first place
this means we have to search our family
list so let's create a search search
function with one parameter x
see what i did there pretty clever we
need to know if bob is even in there to
delete so in order to search we need to
start at the beginning of the list
let's create a temp variable assigned to
the self.head and make a while loop that
will traverse as long as that list or
header isn't empty if any node or temp
node isn't equal to x or whatever it is
we're searching for we want to return
true or else return false
then we need to assign our temp to the
next node because in a while loop it
will need to continue until the node is
not is none then it will return our pool
great let's find out if bob is in there
by printing our search function uh oh
it's true bob's still there and he's
giving amy a hard time about leaving
let's help her out and create a delete
function
this is going to be similar to our other
functions where we need to put our data
in the parameter and begin at the head
of our list
we need our if else statements and we
will
and we will say bob isn't there then
tell us and if he is let's kick him out
we do this by changing the pointers from
the previous node and pointing it to the
node after bob so in essence we're
skipping over bob but watch what happens
when we try to try to delete amy
bob will come back
why does this happen
because our list has four nodes
as created here
and those nodes will always be there
unless we go in and manually delete the
object itself
so far we've traversed our list searched
our list inserted a new header deleted a
node and last but not least we're going
to delete our tail
yep that would be poor jenny
she's had enough of these adult
shenanigans and she's out of here
heading to new york to become the
greatest fashion editor that vogue has
ever known she's ambitious okay
we started the head and as long as the
temp dot next next is not none our
pointer is two nodes ahead we make our
temp the next node and set it to none
voila
best of luck jenny
so there you have it some very basic
foundational algorithms for linked lists
which in itself is a complicated subject
but if you get these classical concepts
down solid it becomes easier and easier
to build up from on your own once you're
more comfortable with singly linked
lists try to challenge yourself with
doubly linked lists with pointers that
point back who knows maybe bob will
shape up and amy will go
or point get it
back to bob
for our mind breakers section in data
structures we're going to be looking at
hash tables right off the rib i'm going
to tell you the key phrases or terms you
need to be familiar with when it comes
to hash tables associative arrays
hash functions
key value pairs collision
and chaining
a hash table consists of an array of
pockets or buckets where each stores a
key value pair in order to locate the
pocket where a key value pair should be
stored the key is passed through a
hashing function
this function returns an integer which
is used as the pairs index in the array
of buckets when we want to retrieve a
key value pair we supply the key to the
same hashing function receive its index
and use the index to find it in the
array
associative arrays can be implemented
with many different underlying data
structures and it refers to an array
with strings as an index rather than
storing element values in a strict
linear index order this stores them in
combination with key values multiple
indices are used to access values in a
multi-dimensional array which contains
one or more arrays a non-performant one
can be implemented by simply storing
items in an array and iterating through
the array when searching remember the
wallet with lots of cash
associative arrays and hash tables are
often confused because associative
arrays are so often implemented as hash
tables according to wikipedia
a hash table uses a hash function to
compute an index also called a hash code
into arrays of buckets or slots from
which the desired value can be found
during lookup the key is hashed and the
resulting hash indicates where the
corresponding value is stored
in many situations hash tables turn out
to be on average more efficient than
search trees or any other table lookup
structure for this reason they are
widely used in many kinds of computer
software particularly for associative
arrays database indexes caches and sets
to summarize we can use hash tables to
store retrieve and delete data uniquely
based on their unique key
the most valuable aspect of a hash table
over other abstract data structures is
its speed to perform insertion deletion
and search operations
hash tables can do
all of them in constant time
for those unfamiliar with time
complexity big o notation constant time
is the fastest possible time complexity
hash tables can perform nearly all
methods except list very fast in o b o
one time
hash tables have to support three
functions
insert for key value
get
key
or delete a key
collision happens when there could
possibly be two or more pieces of data
in
data set x that will hash to the same
integer and data set y
this means that whenever two keys have
the same hash value it's considered a
collision
what should our hash table do if it just
wrote the data into the location anyway
we would be losing the object that is
already stored under a different key
ideally we want our hash values to be
evenly distributed among our buckets as
possible to take full advantage of each
bucket and avoid collisions
but generally speaking this is unlikely
so this is where two common methods to
solve are employed separate chaining
using linked lists or binary search
trees for example and local addressing
using linear probing
with some basic concepts of hash tables
under your belt a fun exercise or
challenge that you can try would be
pattern matching on strings using the
robin carp algorithm
yes it's fairly advanced and yes this is
our mind breaker problem but shoot for
the stars people who knows you might
just surprise yourself
what have we learned what have we
learned from lesson two
okay
we touched on a one-dimensional raise as
our data structure of choice at our
basic level
we looked at contiguous versus
non-contiguous different ways to search
linear
binary
and we sort bubble insert and even
talked about an array with more than one
dimension we learned about dunkles
no no no no we learned about link list
by creating a family of sorts to
demonstrate how to traverse search add
and delete headers
nodes tails on linked lists some of the
most common operations used that every
programmer should be familiar with
we broke our heads on hash tables and
hashing functions by going over what
they are and what can happen when
problems arise from colliding data
within a bucket ultimately hash tables
are for storing retrieving and deleting
data based on key value pairs and on
average are more efficient than search
trees or any other table lookup
structure
[Music]
i learned about the divide and conquer
concept from a very early age
it was traumatizing actually you see my
brother and i used to fight all the time
when we'd swim in the pool and finally
one day our mom came and said to us just
divide it in half and you stand once and
you stay on another side
my brother picked the top half
so yeah divide and conquer
i drowned but only momentarily
in programming when we cross paths with
programs that are too complicated to be
solved all at once we can implement
methods to break them down into smaller
pieces and if we solve all the smaller
pieces we are in essence dividing out
the big
solving the small and in the end this
makes our lives so much easier a divide
and conquer algorithm paradigm can solve
a large problem by recursively breaking
it down into smaller sub-problems until
they become simple enough to be solved
directly it could be compared to the
age-old problem of swallowing an
elephant
can't do that so we devour it one bite
at a time
actually it's more of a solution of
three bytes dividing solving and then
merging it all back together
unfortunately since divide and conquer
algorithms are usually implemented
recursively this means they require
additional memory allocation and without
sufficient memory a stack overflow error
can or will occur
this is due to the overhead of the
repeated subroutine calls along with
storing the call stack the state of each
point in the recursion and that can
outweigh advantages of any approach
on the flip side if the dnc solutions
are implemented by a non-recursive
algorithm that stores the partial sub
problems in some explicit data structure
like a stack queue or priority queue it
can allow more freedom in the choice of
the sub-problem that is to be solved
next a feature that is important in some
applications including breath first
recursion and the branch and brown
branch and bound method
for function optimization
second even if a solution to the full
problem is already known like sorting a
brute force comparison of all elements
with one another divide and conquer can
substantially reduce computational cost
lower cost means higher efficiency
third explicitly recursive subdivision
can have benefits to the temporary
memory of the computer not the main hard
drive
which is called a cache
using divide and conquer one can even
design an algorithm to use all levels of
the cache hierarchy in such a way as to
have an algorithm that is optimally
cached oblivious which means operating
independently from its temporary memory
storage
this approach has been successfully
applied to many problems including
matrix multiplication which we're going
to get into in just a few minutes
so let's get into it and start at the
base level algorithm for divide and
conquer the merge sort
conceptually merge sort works as follows
divide the unsorted list into two sub
lists about half the size
sort each of the two sub lists
merge the two sorted sublists back into
one sorted list
invented by john von neumann in 1945 the
merger sort is an efficient general
all-purpose and comparison-based sorting
algorithm an example of merge sort would
be to first divide the list into the
smallest unit one element this becomes a
list itself
then compare each element which is a
list itself remember with the adjacent
list to sort and merge them done
repetitively the end results in the
elements sorted and merged
i understand that can be a little bit
confusing but let's think of it in this
way
say we have two different lists of
numbers list a and list b and then we'll
have an empty list we'll call c
lists a and b are ordered from least to
greatest and what we would do is
repeatedly compare least value min of a
to the least value min of b and remove
the lesser value and then append that
value into c
when one list is exhausted we append the
the remaining items into c they're
already started so we're good there
then we just return list c which is
sorted we're systematically merging a
and b together and appending it into c
but for this lesson and although you can
append or extend on an empty list to see
we're going to swap our elements i just
wanted to share a very simplistic
explanation for that hoping that would
give you an idea of the concept
typically creating more space for an
empty list or temporary list for storage
isn't always the best approach we want
we want to do our best to optimize our
program if we can
let's head into our ides and write our
programs
the best way to see the different
methods of the merge store and their
efficiencies is to compare four programs
that i have here
some things i wrote myself
some things i borrowed
we're going to look at a single array of
10 integers and just sort it by brute
force this means that the program takes
the first number in index position 0 and
compares it to each and every number in
the array
if it's the lowest it gets reassigned at
the first position
then it moves to the next number and
does the same thing it gets compared to
each and every integer and the lowest
number gets reassigned at index position
one and so on and so forth
for this little iterative program it's
168 iterations or cycles to get an
output and that's just for 10 elements
keep that in mind as we look at the
differences within the merge sort
our first real program for the merge
sort is about as simple as we can get it
we're starting with an array that is
already split in half and sorted the
program we're looking at right now won't
work properly if our two halves are not
already sorted
why
because ultimately this is our divide
and conquer algorithm we are dividing
our array into two parts and conquering
both halves separately by sorting them
and then merging them back together
remember just a few minutes ago when we
talked about list a list b and empty
list c
this program is comparing each number at
each index position determining which is
lower and then popping it out and then
appending it into our empty list c
and
then just in case either list is longer
than the other that leftover portion
just gets added to c and since it's
already sorted we'll have no problems
there
this is a neat little non-recursive
merge sort for an array that has a small
amount of elements and is already
divided in half however since this isn't
a perfect world and you'll be more than
likely asked to write a program for an
array that isn't divided and sorted
beforehand
we're going to have to rewrite this
so here's our big dilemma do we sort our
halves recursively or do we sort them
iteratively
or do we sort our halves using python's
built-in feature called sort or sorted
let's shoot for sorting our halves
recursively this is what is called the
top-down method
what it does is repeatedly produce
sub-lists half by half by half until
there's only one sub-list or one element
remaining which becomes a list all in
itself a list of one element how many of
you are willing to but it's the optimal
or optimized method
well it's not
once we have our have sorted we continue
on very much like before we compare each
element and append it into our empty
list
now if recursion isn't the optimal
method then it must be iteration right
well yes
mostly this is the bottom up method
think of the top down just in reverse it
starts at one element then two elements
then four remember that very first brute
force method of sorting a list we can do
that after we divide the array into two
parts and then merge it all back
together hmm
let's see what happens when we run it in
something like leeco that'll really put
it to the test
[Music]
okay well that didn't go as planned but
it does work it's just bad on really big
arrays
so what is the bust
using python's awesome sort or sorted
feature of course
well splitter array have python sorted
for us and the rest is good to go with
our 10 element array it's only 34 steps
to completion compare that to our brute
force program no dividing no conquering
with almost 170 iterations our bottom up
iterative method is smoking
check it in leak code
talk about optimization
now let's move out into deeper waters
with some matrix multiplication
matrix multiplication is wild y'all
but it is a fundamental concept to
understanding computing among the most
common tools in electrical engineering
and computer science are rectangular
grids of numbers known as matrices the
numbers in a matrix can represent data
and they can also represent mathematical
equations
in many time sensitive engineering
applications multiplying matrices can
give a quick but good approximations of
much more complicated calculations did
you know that one of the areas of
computer science in which matrix
multiplication is particularly useful is
graphics it's crazy to think that a
digital image is basically a matrix with
rows and columns of another matrix
corresponding to rows and columns of
pixels and the numerical entries
correspond to a pixel color value
decoding digital video for instance
requires matrix multiplication and did
you know that mit researchers were able
to build one of the first tips to
implement a high efficiency video coding
standard for ultra high definition tvs
partly because of patterns they
discerned in the matrices
pretty cool huh
so the dimensions are listed as rows and
columns or in many equations n times m
where n represents the number of rows
and n represents the number of columns
be careful that you that you know the
difference between rows and columns and
don't mix them up rows go across columns
go up and down to see how matrices are
multiplied check out this graphic that
shows how it all works we multiply each
element in the row by each element in
the column and then we add them together
in order to code this we'll start with
the naive method it's not too bad to
learn however just know that it can get
very expensive as we increase the size
of our matrices for larger matrix
operations
we wouldn't want to use too many nested
loops because it could really start
bogging down
ideally we would want to use optimized
software packages like numpy
numpy should be the go-to which is
insanely faster and easy too but before
we start cheating we really need to
examine what's going on underneath the
hood like how a program is created that
multiplies matrices in python
because if we can get a really good
handle on this
we'll get a better handle on the mind
breaker
[Music]
okay so what we're doing is basically
creating a calculator in python that
multiplies matrices and you might be
wondering hey what's the deal here how
is this part of dividing and conquering
algorithms we're definitely going to get
into that but this is all preparation
for the mind breaker lesson you'll need
this under your belt first plus it's a
really good foray into matrices which is
one of the most well studied problems in
numerical computing today so yeah let's
dig in
we'll create two matrices x and y and to
store the results of our products we'll
create an empty matrix we'll call result
the most popular method in my humble
opinion is to use nested loops to
iterate over the rows and columns and
implement the results into our matrix of
zeros using an addition operator that
adds our product of the rows
and the columns of x and y
we could do this recursively sure but it
wouldn't really be advantageous the goal
is to help you understand the logic
behind matrix multiplication so we can
move on to our mind breaker lesson
strassen's algorithm for matrix
multiplication
volker strassen is a german
mathematician who made important
contributions to the analysis of
algorithms and has received many awards
over his lifetime he's still alive by
the way
he began his research as a probabilist
his 1964 paper an invariance principle
for the law of the iterated logarithm
defined a functional form of the law of
the iterated logarithm showing a form of
scale scale and variance in random walks
this result now known as strassen's
environments principle or strassen's law
of the iterated logarithm has been
highly cited and led to the 1966
presentation at the international
congress of mathematicians
now if you know what an iterative
logarithm is that shows a form of scale
and variance in random walks or in
variance principles in general well then
please by all means invite us to your
latest book site
but if you're a mere mortal like the
rest of us
hold on to your hats because that was
only the beginning for strassen
three years later strassen shifted his
research efforts toward the analysis of
algorithms with a paper on the gaussian
elimination come on everybody knows what
the gaussian elimination is
and there in that paper he introduced
the first algorithm for performing
matrix matrix multiplication faster than
the o and three time bound that would
result from the naive method
this means that his algorithm is like
the best of the best when it comes to
computing the product of two two by two
matrices there is no formula that uses
fewer than seven multiplications
how he did it he doesn't say maybe
somebody flew into german can call him
up and ask him like what kind of person
do you have to be to discover some great
mathematical algorithm like what are
your hobbies can we talk what do you do
on the weekends i mean at this point at
the time of recording this he's 85 so i
don't know he probably just relaxes his
brain muscles for the most part i mean i
know i would they're probably still
smoking anyway not to knock on this
awesome person and as great as the
algorithm is and the contribution it's
made to matrix multiplication
unfortunately it's too numerically
unstable for some applications
in practice fast matrix multiplication
implementation for dense matrices use
strawson's algorithm for matrix sizes
above a breaking point then they switch
to a simpler method once the subproblem
size reduces to below the breakover see
divide and conquer in any event the
publication of its algorithm did result
in much more research about multi matrix
multiplication that led to faster
approaches it opened the door to bigger
and greater things which is pretty neat
okay now that we've got that all under
our belt let's take a deep dive into
what the algorithm really does just a
few minutes ago we saw the naive method
so you should be somewhat familiar with
it
in two two by two matrices we have eight
multiplications with stress since we can
get this down to seven with basic
mathematical formulas
and i've gotten it all written out so
you can see it all work in a program
let's take a peek
we're still going to keep our 2x2
matrices for simplicity yay
but we're going to look at our famous or
infamous methods of optimization
iteration and recursion for strassen's
algorithm we're dividing our matrices
not by halves but by quarters and then
we'll solve or conquer
each sub-matrix to solve the entire
problem
in our iterative method we're breaking
down the two matrices all the way down
to each individual square or quadrant
we'll name our passes p and simply plug
in our mathematical formula used to
compute our multiplication and addition
on the quadrants
now although we called numpy cheating
we're going to implement it here just
for a little bit of ease by instead
creating a result matrix of zeros we're
going to make a new matrix called c and
number each quadrant of c as c1 c2 c3
and c4 for each quadrant we plug in our
equations for our passes these equations
are our conquered solutions to the
quadrants
lastly we use numpy to implement a new
matrix by using the np dot array feature
and input our four c quadrants
pretty cool
the recursive solution is very similar
only we're recursively splitting the
matrices into our quadrants and
recursively computing our seven passes
what did we learn what did we learn we
learned that the merge store is an
efficient general purpose sort that can
be implemented in several ways including
the top-down and bottom-up approach
we learned that matrix multiplication is
used in simple graphics all the way up
to hd tvs and we wrote our own python
program to calculate two matrices
we looked at strassen's algorithm for
matrix multiplication
and learned that he discovered how to
get the lowest amount of calculations
possible for multiplying two matrices
to this day computational efficiency of
matrix multiplication is still a hot
topic in theoretical computer science
[Music]
apparently if you google greediest
person a real live person does pop up
can you imagine like googling the worst
person in the world and your face gets
blasted on the screen
now i'm not going to show who this
person is because i don't know who he is
and it's not really important just kind
of funny but it does tie in with our
algorithm
what is greed to you like what is a
greedy approach
say your beautiful old granny baked a
pie for your family and uncle bob shows
up you know amy's ex-husband
and he takes the biggest piece of pie
for himself that'd be pretty greedy
wouldn't it by him eating the largest
portion that sure would make the pie
easier to finish wouldn't it it wouldn't
be great for everyone else or their
rumbling tummies but by taking the
biggest portion and leaving just little
portions to take care of
that's
sort of the concept behind the algorithm
the paradigm behind the green concept is
that it builds up a solution piece by
piece always choosing the next piece
that offers the mo the obvious and most
immediate benefit
by using several iterations and by
obtaining the best result at a certain
iteration the results should be computed
in other words it follows the
problem-solving method of making the
locally optimum choice at each stage
with the hope of finding the global
optimum something to keep in mind though
is that they do not consistently find
the globally optimum solution because
generally speaking they don't operate
exhaustively on all the data
nevertheless they are useful because
they are quick and often give good
approximations to the optimum if a
greedy algorithm can be proven to yield
the global optimum for a given problem
class it typically becomes the method of
choice
a really fun problem that we can lead
off with is called assign mice to holes
what we need to do is put every mouse to
its nearest hole to minimize the time
how can we do that and what's the
optimal approach
what would you think about sorting the
positions of the mice and holes first
that would be pretty greedy of us
wouldn't it
this allows us to put a particular mouse
closest to the corresponding hole in the
holes list we can then find the maximum
difference between the mice and the
corresponding hole position to determine
how much time it will take to get there
now does being greedy always equate to
maximum of something regarding problem
solutions not necessarily don't let that
word fool you
for this problem we're finding the
maximum difference hint subtraction to
find the minimum amount of time it takes
for our mice to travel
as a quick side note another problem
that i would encourage you to learn on
your own a triple dog dare you is the
kids with greatest candies problem using
the greedy approach
this is considered an easy problem so
don't worry too much the problem is
similar to this one by asking for the
distribution of the minimum number of
candies that can be given to a kid
and then seeing which kid will contain
the maximum number of candies
so again the greedy approach can be
tricky we have to carefully decipher
word usages to make sure we're solving
the problem accurately
but with that being said the assigned
mice to holes problem will help set you
on some solid ground and make it a bit
easier to work on other challenges now
if you do decide to tackle the candy
problem and i do highly encourage you to
do that i'll give you a little hint
the brute force method would be a one by
one distribution of candies to each
child until the condition satisfies
and yet the greedy way would be to
traverse the array just twice from
beginning to end and back again by
greedily determining the minimum number
of candies required by each child
as a personal challenge to yourself work
out how that could be written it'll be
fun let's head over to our ides and slam
dunk some mice into holes
okay we need to get our mice into holes
and we have to do it quickly but first
things first we have to make sure that
there are an equal amount of holes to
our mice this is our base
now
we initialize our greedy approach by
sorting the mice first then we create a
variable to store our maximum difference
and loop through the length of our mice
in our if statement we create the
condition that if the position of the
mouse subtracted from the position of
the hole is greater than the maximum
difference
our max diff variable gets reassigned to
hold that difference
lastly we just return the largest
difference our last mouse gets to the
hole in x amount of time
by sorting our two lists first this puts
us at an advantage to finding the
minimum time faster
our code is concise short and along with
python's sort feature we are really
rocking it out
next up is kind of a doozy the
fractional knapsack a pretty well known
problem for our greedy algorithm
if you were a little bored with our mice
and no holes you won't be with the
knapsack
for a step up on the greedy method let's
take a peek into what's called the
fractional knapsack now this is intense
fractional knapsack freshness people
okay so this problem on the surface
seems really complicated but it's only
as complicated as you want to make it
you know what i mean so let's not make
it complicated okay so just so what you
can do is just envision me it's the
apocalypse it's the end of the world
wait maybe it's just a monday food is
scarce people are bartering water is
practically non-existent so i need to
conserve every bit of energy i have to
walk to the market and try to trade what
i have to stay alive okay now i have
five objects i can take our knapsack or
bag is our container for holding our
objects think of our array as a storage
device
and each object is worth something some
are worth more than others and each
object weighs something some objects way
more than others the key to this problem
is to make the right decision on which
objects are going to bring me the most
profit i mean i gotta know i have
animals to feed
that haven't become somebody else's
dinner you know while at the same time
they can't be too heavy that i can't
carry in my container because this is
crucial i might have to make a decision
based on its object the weight of the
object not necessarily its profit if i
want to make it back alive from zombies
r us
now the real kick in the head on solving
this
lies in that little teeny tiny word
fractional this means that my objects
can be divided if they are divisible
say one of my objects contains three
chapsticks i can divide that object and
bring only two chapsticks if it will
make a difference who knows cat fat
might be a real hot commodity remember
in that book of eli movie where he
killed that cat
well it was for food but he also made
chapstick out of it
not saying my chapstick would be that
it'd probably be made from beeswax or
something
don't forget i'm risking my brains to go
to the market to feed my animals in the
first place so no cancel be harmed here
no siree bob okay wow that was a really
long
way off the beaten path if let's get
back to the problem so the weight is
divisible and it would help to best fit
how many profitable objects in my
backpack then we should do that why we
need to fill to the brim in our fixed
size knapsack the most valuable items
that we are able to carry
for the steps of our algorithm keep in
mind we are given weights and values of
n items and we need to put these items
in a knapsack of capacity w to get the
maximum total value in the knapsack by
the way in the o1 knapsack problem a
whole different problem is one where
we're not allowed to break items down or
divide them using fractions
we either take the whole item or don't
take it but in this problem fractions
can be used
a really efficient solution to this
problem is to use the greedy approach as
opposed to brute force remember brute
force is calculating every possible
solution and is typically
computationally expensive meaning it
takes a lot of runtime and memory space
the basic idea is to calculate the ratio
of value slash weight for each item and
sort the item on the basis of this ratio
then take the item with the highest
ratio greedy remember and add them until
we can't add the next item as a whole
and at the end add the next item as much
as we can
this will generally always be the
optimal solution to this problem
you'll see what i mean when we get into
our ides and start coding it so let's
get to work
okay
we'll define our functions with three
parameters
we need our values our weights and the
capacity of the bag
now we have our created variables here
but i implemented print calls to show
you what's going on
we have our items a range of zero to
four equaling five items
the ratios are values divided by weight
using floor division to eliminate floats
list comprehension is good to use when
you can
then we'll sort our ratios in decreasing
order
lastly the ratios index positions are
printed here to show the to show you the
order that it will be computed in
i'm going to
take out the third variable here it as
it won't be needed
i just wanted to show you how it matches
up with its index position
our ratios being sorted is taken care of
in the items.sort line
we need a counter to keep a running
tally of our max value
we will create a list that is the length
of our values we'll call fractions that
will contain all zeros
i'll tell you why we're doing this at
the end of the program now it's time to
run our for loop we'll iterate over our
items and if the weight of our item is
less than capacity it will add a one to
our fractions list of zeros at its index
position then we'll add that value to
our max value and subtract the weight
from our capacity now when all those
conditions satisfy and we hit our else
we take the fractional difference of our
last item and add it to our max value
then we return our maximum value which
is 500 now here's the key you might be
wondering this
we have an item that weighs
a 10 and it's worth 90.
at a capacity of 150 we could put 15
of these items into our bag for a value
of 15 times 90 equaling 1350.
why can't we just do that
we can't do that because what we're
looking at today is what is called the
bounded knapsack problem or bkp for
short
the scenario i just painted a 15
15 of the same items would be allowing
for copies of that item called the
called the ukp type short for unbounded
knapsack problem and that's a whole
other ball of wax kids
this is why we set up the fractions list
containing nothing but zeros
this is important because it's putting
in our highest values first
and then taking a fraction of the last
item from maximum capacity in our bag
each item counts as one in our fractions
list until every zero is turned into a
one but our very last item to change
from zero to one is that special one
that gets the remaining capacity divided
by the weight
that figure gets multiplied to our value
and then added to our max value in the
case of our program that ends up being
28 and a half percent and what's 28 and
a half percent of 140
is the value of 40 that puts us up to
500. sorting our ratios in decreasing
order gives us the optimal or best
approach this is considered greedy as
you are placing items with the largest
ratios into our bag first
now you can sort by price and you can
sort by weight as those are considered
methods and they will get you close to
500
but it's just not 500. and we should
always strive for the best method
algorithmically
hopefully you now understand a pretty
well-known problem not only in logistics
but other fields as well like
manufacturing and finance it's all about
optimization
what is the optimal way to get the items
of highest value into a bag that you can
reasonably carry
and this greedy concept can be carried
out in other reasonable scenarios as
well
with the goal of calculating solutions
whether that be approximations or actual
figures
let's move on to our last section with
good old fibonacci
in our mind breaker episode we're going
to talk about another well-known
mathematician leonardo alpisa aka
fibonacci considered to be the most
talented western mathematician of the
middle ages
according to wikipedia he wrote the
libre abachi the book of calculation and
is it is a historic 13th century latin
manuscript on arithmetic which includes
the posing and solving of a problem
involving the population growth of
rabbits based on idealized assumptions
the solution
generate generation by generation of
rabbit offspring was a sequence of
numbers later known as the famous
fibonacci numbers or fibonacci sequence
in a little side compartment of
mathematics however what we are going to
talk about today is the greedy algorithm
for egyptian fractions first described
by fibonacci for transforming rational
numbers into egyptian fractions
an egyptian fraction is a representation
of an irreducible fraction as a sum of
distinct unit fractions and this means
that every positive fraction can be
represented as a sum of unique unit
fractions a fraction is a unit fraction
if the numerator is 1 and the
denominator is a positive integer for
example 1 3
is a unit fraction to take a closer look
we'll reduce a fraction of 7 14 in a
pizza example the egyptian way
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
in order to generate egyptian fractions
we will utilize the greedy algorithm
because although possible to use brute
force search algorithms to find it it
would be extremely inefficient
remember 3d algorithms are for
optimizing our problems we always want
to know and understand the optimal
solution as a side note although
fibonacci's greedy algorithm isn't the
only way to efficiently solve our
problem he's our focus for today
let's look at a program
so yeah i got this program here
we're importing some tools
scroll down some
we got three functions going strong a
main a validate a converting function we
got some wrappers nestled functions we
got some yields which means it's a
generator not even gonna touch that
this is a lot of code
heading into nearly 50 lines
is it good
yes
hard to write
depends but if you're looking for
kindergarten style programming you come
to the right place
i totally dumbed it down to show you the
mechanics not that you're dumb i love
simple make it plain am i right
so we have this pie remember that bob
took a big old chunk of let's change
that to a pizza since it kind of goes
with our theme of leonardo of pizza
or fibonacci
so to get this real simple we'll write a
function that takes our numerator and
our denominator
we'll implement an empty list for our
denominators we won't need one for our
numerators because we already know that
they're going to be ones
then we write our while loop that as
long as our numerator isn't zero we can
create a variable that stores our
quotient using the math dot seal that
will round it up
this is important for when we have a
number that's a float lower than one
next we reassign our numerator to be the
product of the quotient and the
difference of our denominator subtracted
from our numerator then we reassign our
denominator to be multiplied by our
quotient or x
for our fraction of 7 12 this is going
to put a 2 and a 12 into our egypt list
and those two numbers are our lowest
common denominators or lcd for short
all that's left to do now is put a 1
over those lcds as those are our
egyptian fractions and that can be
accomplished a few ways but basically i
just implemented some good old-fashioned
string formatting by iterating over our
egypt list of denominators and adding
them to an empty string
once we do that we just return it the
caveat to this really simple program is
that it probably doesn't work for really
complex fractions or when the numerator
is larger than the denominator
but this is a good exercise in
understanding how to break down a
fraction the egyptian way ultimately all
of this runs more along the line of
recreational mathematics however there
are still open problems involving
egyptian fractions that have yet to be
solved or proved
who knows maybe you can be the next
mathematical genius to solve one of them
so what did we learn about greedy
algorithms we learned optimization of
solutions to problems using the greedy
algorithm provided in our example with
the mice in the holes it's like a
delicious big pie where you take the
biggest slice out first
this makes the pie easier to finish we
learned that chapstick made from cats is
a hot commodity in the apocalypse
kidding
we walk through the fractional nap stack
problem where we find the largest value
of an item in a way to maximize the
total value within the knapsack we want
to avoid brute force here because
finding all the possible subsets would
take too much time we learned that
fibonacci was the first to describe an
algorithm for transforming rational
numbers into egyptian fractions and it
is where we really take the largest unit
fraction we can and then and then repeat
that on the remainder although this is
purely mathematics it's still a good
representation of the greedy algorithm
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think when you hear the word
dynamic
well if you're a programmer or an
aspiring programmer
you may not know what to think
what does being dynamic really mean
for once in my life it would be awesome
to be described as dynamic because when
we talk about a dynamic person
it means energetic
spirited
active
lively
zestful vital
vigorous
maybe this is why when it comes to
computer science students can become
intimidated with the subject of dynamic
programming
ultimately the word dynamic means a
process or system characterized by
constant change activity or progress
with its roots in greek to the word
dynamous meaning power
hint dynamite
so it's no wonder we subconsciously shy
away from it because it just sounds like
a handful it dangerous pretty wild how
words and their meanings really deep
down can make us feel a certain way you
know
but i'm here to help you out and put you
at ease and tell you a little secret
they introduce dynamic programming to
children
okay maybe not children children but
like upper elementary middle schoolers
kids like that so if they can learn
about it so can you
but first we have to unplug our
preconditioned mentality if you will to
think and believe that anything in
computer science is too hard
it's not it's all just one big treasure
hunt to find information and knowledge
that best suits your intellectual filter
not all people teach all things the same
way
not all people learn information or
absorb knowledge the same way so let's
take a deep breath and step back to look
at the different dynamics that are out
there
that's a long list
for us there should only be two that
should really mean something
that's dynamic programming languages and
dynamic programming as a methodology you
can have programming languages that are
either dynamic or static python is
dynamic by the way and then you have
programming methodologies that are
concerned with analyzing a problem by
developing algorithms based on modern
programming techniques
in the world of dynamic programming
dp is used when the solution to a
problem can be viewed as a result of a
sequence of decisions with the intended
outcome of reducing run time and any
implementation that can make a solution
more efficient is considered optimizing
it
in an early lesson we saw several
problems that can be viewed in this way
i.e the knapsack problem
essentially the difference between the
greedy method and dp is that in the
greedy method only one decision sequence
is ever generated and in dp many
decision sequences may be generated
however sequences containing sub-optimal
sub-sequences cannot be optimal and as
far as possible will not be generated
and this is the key that helps make a
reduced run time optimal substructure
means that optimal solutions of
subproblems can be used to find the
optimal solutions of the overall problem
in dp this is called the principle of
optimality the principle of optimality
as relayed by richard bellman who
introduced dynamic programming in 1953
states that an optimal policy has the
property that whatever the initial state
and initial decision are the remaining
decisions must constitute an optimal
policy with regard to the state
resulting from the first decision
so what does that mean
in general we can solve a problem with
optimal substructure by doing three
things
breaking the problem down into smaller
sub problems
solving the sub problems recursively
and then using the optimal solutions to
construct an optimal solution for the
original problem
but there's an issue with this that we
need to be aware of and that is
sometimes when we do this we can get
overlapping subproblems we want to avoid
that
for instance in the fibonacci sequence
f3 equals f1 plus f2 and f4 equals f2
plus f3 computing each number involves
computing f2 because both f3 and f4 are
needed to compute f5 a naive approach to
computing f5 may end up computing f2
twice or more
in order to avoid this we instead save
or store the solutions to problems we
have already solved in dynamic
programming there are three basic
methods
we have recursion
top down with memoization and bottom up
with tabulation
and although we could have chosen the
well-worn path of the fibonacci sequence
to do this
oh no
i'm encouraging you to step out and
think bigger have confidence
you are smart and you can do big things
so
let's get ugly with it in our first
lesson
what are ugly numbers and why do we call
them ugly and what do we do with them
to answer the first question i saw this
and i think it will give you a big hint
okay
that's funny and i wish i could have
been the one to think it up but alas i
was too slow to the game
darn
i stumbled upon a pretty funny thread
about ugly numbers and i stole that so
shh don't tell on me
but the long and short of it is this
to check if a number is ugly in the
first place
we divide the number by the greatest
divisible powers of two three and five
and if the number becomes one
then it's an ugly number otherwise it's
not
we're employing our power of prime
factorization
we learned that way back in the fifth
grade so that tells me that you probably
don't remember
but it'll all come back to you today
the sequence of one to six eight nine 10
12 15 shows the first 11 ugly numbers by
convention one is included
all right now that you got that under
your belt let's tackle the problem of
finding the nth ugly number
can we find the hundredth ugly number
would you believe that if we crafted a
program using brute force it would be
over a thousand iterations
for the hundredth number
i think i broke my visualizer trying to
run it
and we don't want to break things or
make our computers smoke out the back or
anything like that so it's time to
incorporate our spirited energized
vigorous programming that's like
dinomite but not a lot of dynamite
we'll start small and just find the 15th
ugly number how does that sound
since we're going big and not going home
we're gonna shoot for the bottom up
method for a dynamic approach
if we use a pretty simple iterative with
some recursion solution we're still
looking at nearly 600 steps or
iterations in the program
to get our results as compared to just a
little over a hundred steps for the
bottom-up dynamic programming method
talk about optimization
if we use simple iteration and
continuously loop through all the
numbers to find whether each number is
ugly or not it can really bog down when
we get to larger numbers
with dynamic programming instead of
starting from the head we start from the
bottom we're also using a table to help
us store the values for easy access if
we look at the ugly number sequence 1 to
6 8 9 10 12 15 we can see that it can be
further divided into sub sequences of 2
3 and 5. and these subsequences
themselves are ugly numbers therefore we
take every ugly number from the above
sequences and choose the smallest ugly
number in every step to make sure that
we don't miss any number in between
let's head into our ides
okay so if we're looking for the nth
ugly number in a sequence we have to
write a function that will tell us if
our numbers
can be evenly divided in the first place
meaning no remainder
x modulo y equaling 0 gives us what we
need to prove that if there is a
remainder we'll just write it to return
our original number for our second step
before we can find the nth ugly number
position we have to check if it's an
ugly number we can do this recursively
by going back to our first function the
successive division
what this does is plug in the number
we're checking and successively or
successfully if you want to think of it
that way dividing it by two three and
five if our number is successfully
divided by two three and five with no
remainder we have an ugly number on our
hands let's check a six
it's true six is ugly
okay so we have what we need to find our
nth number six is fairly easy since
every number before it is ugly so the
sixth ugly number is
six but what's the 15th number well
let's write a program to find out
essentially what we're doing is merely
creating a counter coupled with
recursively calling back our ugly check
function we'll create two variables one
for i to iterate up our sequence and one
for our counter and then we just
incorporate a while loop to say as long
as our number is greater than our
counter we'll add one to i heading up
our number sequence and if that number
within our while loop is ugly add a 1 to
our counter
then we just return i
so what's our 15th ugly number
it's 24.
now if we run this program we have a lot
of running back in our recursive calls
for every number in our sequence
and that's a lot of running back with
600 steps or iterations that's a lot
considering with dp we can write a much
more efficient program that cuts all
those iterations by nearly 80 percent
let's check out the difference the first
major thing we can do is eliminate those
three functions within our original
program we won't need those remember
when i said we were going to implement a
table to store information
well that's what we're doing then we'll
start our first position in that table
or in other words a dynamic programming
array to store the ugly numbers next set
pointers for our multiples of 2 3 and 5
and we can do this all in one line which
is pretty cool you'll see how this works
as we get deeper into the program here's
our multiples of two three and five in
their own variables after that we loop
from one to n at each step and we find
the minimum ugly number out of three
multiples and store it in our dp array
we're also increasing the pointer for
the number whose multiple has been added
and replace it by its next multiple so
suppose a multiple of two has been added
to the array we increase twos pointer by
one and multiply the previous multiple
to two to get the next multiple and so
on and so forth for other numbers as
well and this way starting from the base
case we generate all the ugly numbers
and then apply dynamic programming to
store the numbers in the array until we
get the nth ugly number
this approach is way better than the
previous one because instead of checking
all the numbers for being ugly we just
used the previous ugly numbers to
generate new ones
watch how this runs through the program
this really is the better way
very efficient now let's put this
knowledge to good use on a very famous
problem called the traveling salesman
problem
if you haven't heard of this yet you
will
best to get it in your brain bucket now
rather than later
the traveling salesman problem is one of
the most intensely studied and famous
problems in computational mathematics
with its main main really main focus on
optimization
so much research has gone into this
challenge of finding the cheapest
shortest fastest route in the visitation
of locations by this dashingly handsome
or beautiful salesperson
this person starts in their home city
travels around and returns to their
starting point most easily expressed in
a graph
the general form of the tsp traveling
salesperson appears to have been first
studied by mathematicians during the
1930s in vienna and at harvard notably
by karl menger
menger defines the problem considers the
brute force algorithm and observes the
non-optimality of the nearest neighbor
heuristic using the mailman as an
example now the order in which the
person travels isn't cared about as long
as he visits each one
once during his trip
and finishes where he was at the first
in the most cost effective way but
there's a catch
maybe the salesman needs to take a plane
to one of the cities and this will cost
him a pretty penny
maybe he can walk to one of his cities
therefore making it a free trip the cost
associated with the trip describes how
difficult it is to to traverse the
journey or graph for us computer
scientists whether that's money or time
or distance required to complete the
traversal the salesman ideally wants to
keep every cost as low as possible he
wants the cheapest fastest shortest
route wouldn't you the easiest and most
expensive solution
is to simply try all the permutations
and then see which one is cheapest using
brute force the problem with this though
is that for n cities you have n minus 1
factorial possibilities this means that
just for 10 cities there are over 180
000 combinations to try since the start
city is defined there could be
permutations on the remaining nine
and at 20 cities this just becomes
simply infeasible
this is why four is often used in the
majority of problems as you'll quite
often see in the 4x4 matrices keeping it
small makes it much more manageable and
understandable which is good
the awesome news for us is that the
problem is solvable but keep in mind
that there can also be solutions to the
problems that are approximations or
commonly called heuristic algorithms if
that's what is being asked for according
to wikipedia even though the problem is
computationally difficult many
heuristics and exact algorithms are
known so that some instances with tens
of thousands of cities can be solved and
even problems with millions of cities
can be approximated within a fraction of
one percent
wow
so let's get to the nitty gritty and
look at our steps number one consider
city one as the starting and ending
point
number two generate all n
one factorial permutations of cities
three calculate cost of every
permutation and keep track of minimum
cost permutation four return the
permutation with minimum cost
it's not hard to see how this could get
computationally expensive in a very
short amount of time so we will move
into the optimize method right away for
our savings
and our sanity
the goal is to break this problem down
into the smallest pieces possible and
then solve solve solve
let's get into it
because permutations are a big part of
the tsp problem we're going to import
intertools permutations to make our
lives a whole lot easier
it's totally okay for this one
we'll implement a variable that we'll
call v
short for vertices and vertices are the
dots on our graph think of our sales
person traveling to four cities on our
graph a single dot is called a vertex
on our graph and they link or connect to
one another now we can move on to
implementing our function call here with
two parameters our graph that will be a
four by four matrix and s is going to be
our counter that will need to calculate
the sum of our path i'll explain this a
little bit deeper at the end of the
program
we'll create an empty list for our
vertices to be stored in and we'll call
this vertex just to make it plain this
is going to tell us the best route for
our rows in the graph again this is
going to be come real clear at the end
of the program so hold on to yourselves
then we iterate over our range of v and
if the index does not equal us which is
zero we append it to our empty vertex
list this is going to show us where our
salesperson is traveling within the
graph but here's a little catch that we
need to be aware of check out our graph
see those trails of zeros
we have no need to calculate those so
when we append our indices to our vertex
list we're only producing three integers
one two and three
next we create another empty list that
we'll call min path
we need to know the best route so this
will store our lowest combination of
vertices within the graph
then we create a variable that we'll
call next permutation and we'll
implement the inter tools permutations
module here to give us all the
combinations of the vertices for one two
and three
since we have three numbers we know that
the amount of permutations will be six
then we iterate over all those
combinations and create a counter that
we'll call current pathway we'll
reassign our s to a variable we'll call
k and k will represent the row in our
graph
and as we iterate over our indices
within our permutations by using j
this becomes our columns i know this
sounds i know this all sounds really
confusing but stay with me when we add
the k and j of our graph to our current
pathway look what prints out
this is calculating all the paths within
our graph and adding them together
pretty cool isn't it
next we reassign k to j and then use an
addition operator to add the sums to our
graph to the current pathway append them
to our min pass hold them in a variable
called x that's sorted
and simply return the very first number
in our sorted list which is our lowest
number
our shortest route on the graph to see
how this travels
on the graph watch this
this is how it is adding up within our
program
hopefully you can see and understand how
this is all working it sounds so much
more complicated than it really is but
it's only math
we're simply calculating the paths of a
matrix by pulling out all the
combinations or permutations of the
indices and returning the lowest number
or lowest sum of the path it's not too
bad my recommendation to you would be to
create your own graph and then run it in
the program once you do that
map that course on paper or even
whiteboard it to see it visually
for our very last lesson today and not
only for dp but
all together
i'm so sad to leave you
so let's make this session a great one
what we're doing for our mindbreaker
sounds really intimidating but i can
assure you that once we break this down
you're gonna say wow that wasn't even
that bad and then you can brag to all
your friends and then they'll shun you
for your genius
but it'll be totally worth it i i mean
because who needs friends am i right
now your brain won't break too much if
we take each word out and examine it
first we have palindromic which is
religious palindrome matrix we'll keep
it low and slow with a 3x3
and then just paths which we're only
going to go right and down only
since we worked on a matrix in our last
problem this should be old hat hopefully
by now you have a decent handle on
breaking down the problem into smaller
ones called sub problems and solving
them little by little in order to solve
the whole
tips for getting started on the
palindromic matrix path problem would be
to first know how to check whether a
string is a palindrome or not in the
first place
you can use python's python has a little
pip install program called
palindrome that
checks whether a string is pendulum or
not but i do highly recommend you learn
how to do this on your own
because it will help with this problem
the second tip would be knowing how to
traverse a matrix going right and down
only
we're not going to get too crazy for our
final lesson and just have some fun with
it by printing our palindrome strings
we're not going to return counts or find
the longest because that might make some
of us cry
and there will be no crying today any
tears that gets shed must be happy tears
only whether that's joy at finishing
this course or not seeing my face
anymore
tears of accomplishment are fine but no
tears of sadness okay to keep it simple
we'll start at ground zero and start
with an empty three by three matrix and
find all the unique paths
what's really cool about this is that
it's actually just a math problem
what we'll do is create in our three by
three by starting with a row of ones
that we will build up from
our bottom row and far right column will
be ones and when we add their adjacent
numbers together and build up we get a
row of ones one one one at the bottom
and then three two one in the middle and
then six three one at the top
if we return row zero
that will give us six and that tells us
that we have six unique paths in our
matrix
this will come in handy later when we
implement this principle into our matrix
of strings
we can know that we will have six
strings returned to us and all we need
to do is check whether they're
palindromes and print those out
so we're not going to talk much if at
all about the naive approach or brute
force or whatever the difference is in
optimization no
let's part ways on a good note and have
some fun with this
i mean we walked through 14 other
problems with multiple methods in a
relatively short amount of time
and here we are breaking our minds on
palindromic matrix paths so yeah let's
get straight to the optimum let's code
the paths problem first shall we we'll
start by creating our function with two
parameters our row and our column we
already know it's going to be a three by
three then we create our dynamic
programming array of all ones which you
can envision as our bottom row of ones
next we iterate over our rows in a for
loop and then create another dp array
which can be envisioned as an
accumulative next row up in our matrix
our original for loop is going to
iterate three times 0 1 2
for each row in our matrix in a second
for loop we now want to iterate from the
bottom up and reassign our new row
elements by adding one element to the
one next to it going left
we do this twice
while in our final iteration it has
accumulated each row to end with six
three one we then reassign our original
row as the final row and return the very
first element which will be six
our answer to the number of paths now
this isn't super necessary but it will
give you an idea of the path traversal
within a three by three matrix and will
give us a good launch point to moving up
to a matrix consisting of letters we'll
keep it in the realm of just two letters
a
and b and we'll write a very quick
little program to see how many
palindromes of a and b there are
let's import intertools to help us and
then create our rows and columns of
letters
a neat little feature of inter tools is
product with an asterisk on our matrix
this will print out every combination of
letters in our matrix totaling 27. yes
there will be duplicates here but it's
nothing that python's set can't handle
let's create an empty list called p1 and
then iterate over our list of 27 tuples
join them together to make it easy on
the eyes and append them to our empty
list
then all that's left to do is check
which ones are palindromes by making a
new function plugging in our p1 create
another empty list p2 and then iterating
over a non-duplicate set of p1
incorporate an if statement is it a
palindrome yes put it in our empty list
then return it
okay so far we've traversed a matrix in
order to count the number of paths in it
we created a three by three matrix of
just two letters found every possible
combination and created a function to
pull the palindromes from it
we are doing fabulously if you know how
to count the paths of a matrix and find
the palindromes in a matrix you're
totally equipped to take on the
palindromic paths problem
let's get cracking
so
before we start i have to tell you
there's going to be a little bit of a
difference here for this program
it's the order of traversal we're going
to go from the top and right to the
bottom not the bottom up and left to the
top
so keep that in mind as we march forward
we're going to throw in our little
palindrome checker up here first before
we print them out at the end of our
function hopefully by now you're
familiar with that
next we're going to create our main
function with several parameters
a string that will be empty but we're
just going to call it string here
a for our array
our pointers that we'll call i and j
our row and column that we'll call m and
n
now our conditional if statements are
going to traverse the paths of our array
we minus one from m and n because as you
know this is python and we only need to
iterate from indices starting at zero
then one then two for our total size of
rows and columns three by three see the
i plus one and the j plus one within our
recursive callbacks look at these slides
to see the paths
you could also print i and j within the
conditional statements on your own to
see it as well but when we add one to
our pointers we're moving to the next
element then
once the traversal is completed it hits
our else statement and that hits up our
palindrome checker if it's true it'll
print then it moves on to do the next
reversal over and over until it's done
and there you have it
four palindrome strings in our matrix
yay
[Applause]
so what did we learn on our final lesson
we learned about dynamic programming
which is finding the optimal solution to
sub problems that can be used to find
the optimal solutions to the overall
problem
we saw this in our lesson with ugly
numbers the traveling salesman problem
and palindromic matrix paths
in the easy lesson we learned about ugly
numbers what they are and how to write a
program to find the nth ugly number in
the sequence avoiding brute force and
recursion we were able to implement
dynamic programming to optimize the
solution from over one thousand
iterations down to just a little over
one
we looked at the very famous traveling
salesman problem with its main focus in
optimizing a solution to finding the
most efficient route a solution used
across the board for so many companies
in order to keep operational costs low
and lastly we broke down the mind
breaker lesson by studying unique paths
in a matrix
string palindromes within a matrix and
combining those two problems together to
find all the palindromic paths within a
matrix
are you excited i know that i am we
covered so much ground in this course
it's crazy
hopefully you took lots of notes so you
can practice later you should be coding
something every day even if it's just
for a couple minutes 10 to 15. since
every little bit helps now listen to
your mother thank you so much for
joining me today and if you made it all
the way here kudos to you i wish you all
the best in your programming journey bye